I'm in, baby.
I'm in all day long.
Narrator: There's only one...
"Shark Tank",
the original business show.
We're asking
for $100,000...
...for a 15% stake.
I would like 33 1/3%.
Ooh!
Herjavec: Yowza!
Narrator:
Through thick and thin,
"Shark Tank" is still here.
Uplifting...
I may only be 17,
but I was made to be
an entrepreneur.
You have something
magical happening.
You gotta pour fuel
on the fire.
Narrator: ...inspiring...
Grede: It's really difficult
for Black women.
But guess who's sitting
right in front of you,
who has done it
over and over again.
Narrator: ...a steadfast
champion for everyday Americans
fulfilling their dreams.
We've done over
$1.6 million.
-Wow!
-Son of a gun!
-What?!
Bananas to the moon, baby!
Narrator: And this season,
exciting brand-new guest Sharks
join the Tank.
Gwyneth Paltrow.
The Oscar-winning actress
is also a powerhouse
entrepreneur and founder of
lifestyle juggernaut goop.
Paltrow: We are putting
amazing things into the world.
We have so many stories
of changing lives.
Narrator: And Tony Xu, founder
of the largest food delivery
platform in America, DoorDash.
Xu: We contributed
almost $70 billion
to the U. S. economy,
and we're just getting started.
Narrator: And exciting titans of
business return to the Tank.
I'm a brand builder. I built
my own from the ground up
out of my extra bedroom.
I bring a lot
to the party.
You've got Mr. Wonderful
and Mr. Global.
I love you, man, because
you're hanging by a thread
and you don't give up.
If either one of us
don't do this deal,
our lives are not
gonna change.
We're still gonna be
[bleep] rich.
Narrator: The brand new season
has begun.
Bad entrepreneur!
You've seen the show before!
Wait, wait.
Did I hear a dollar a unit?
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding, ding.
No, no, Mr. Wonderful.
No, no, no, no, no.
What if we could create
a new standard
for the digital age and get
the whole world typing
at the speed of thought?
Wow.
Aah!
I will work like a lion.
Bet on me.
Aaah!
[ Laughs ]
Woman: I needed this so bad.
I'm just so thankful to God.
I'm Mr. Wonderful.
I'm gonna make you filthy rich.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is an adorable way
to learn a new skill.
Corcoran: Hey.
Cuban: Oh, my goodness.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Sharks. We're Justine.
And Adrian.
The wife and husband team
behind The Woobles.
Today we're seeking
a $250,000 investment
in exchange for a 5% equity
in our company.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Wow.
Sharks, we're here
to get you hooked.
On crochet.
Our company is
The Woobles.
We make fun, simple kits
that teach you how to crochet.
But instead of
a boring potholder,
you'll learn how to make
adorable characters like...
Pierre the penguin
and Felix the fox.
Fred the dino
and Sebastian the lion.
Each kit comes with
step-by-step videos
that teach complete beginners
how to crochet.
Our secret -- we're not just
a crochet company.
We see ourselves
as an education company, too.
We've seen that something
magical happens
when people
learn a new skill.
It's about confidence.
So, Sharks, who is ready
to Wooble with us?
[ Laughter ]
Super cute.
Thank you.
What you have in front
of you is both a kit
and an example of
The Wooble
that you would make
with this kit.
And if you open up
the pouch,
then you'll see
our easy peasy yarn.
And then, most importantly,
there's a card inside
of the pouch that has
a link and a QR code
that brings you
to our website tutorial
our customers will follow to
learn how to make that Wooble.
What is the age
start for this?
So most people will look
at our product
and think that it's for kids,
but most of our customers
are actually adults
buying it for themselves.
And what do you sell
these for,
and what do they cost
you to make?
Landed, they're $3.
We wholesale for $15,
and we retail for $30.
Wow.
Herjavec: How do you sell them?
Over 90% of our sales
are direct to consumer,
straight from our website.
Wow.
Corcoran: So what made you
crochet in the first place?
Before I started
The Woobles,
I used to lead user experience
for Google Classroom.
Oh, really?
And I spent the bulk
of my career
as a UX designer
working on education products.
And I loved my job.
I was great at it.
I was so great that
they made me a manager,
and it turns out
I sucked at being a manager.
[ Laughter ]
And so to take
my mind off of work,
I started dabbling in
all these other hobbies,
and crochet was
one of those things.
And learning to crochet
reminded me that I still
have it in me to
learn something new,
that I could try to become
a better manager.
And so that experience
of really building
back my confidence
through crochet
is why we started this.
I want to share that
experience.
Are you still at Google?
Oh, no, no, no.
This is a 100% full time.
Is it full time
for both of you?
Yes.
And what's your
background?
From a really young age,
I've been taught that success
means getting good grades,
going to a good school,
and getting
a really high-paying job.
And that's
exactly what I did.
So I became one of the youngest
directors on Wall Street.
I traded billions of dollars
in equities.
Wow.
But I wasn't any happier
at the end of it
than when I started.
And what I began to realize
was that I had spent
all that time working
towards someone else's
definition of success.
And so I left it
all behind to go
and try and figure out what
my own definition of success is.
I knew from
a really young age
that I really liked
helping people,
and then when we started
thinking about crochet kits,
what's really neat about it
is that it is that
confidence boost.
Sometimes as we get older,
you kind of stop
learning new things,
you start saying things like,
"You know,
I'm too old to learn that."
And so what brings me joy
with these kits
is that they're
a little confidence boost
to remind you that you can
always learn something new.
So exactly two years ago,
we started this business.
We took $200,
we bought some yarn,
and we bought
a domain name.
And since then,
we've done $5.3 million.
-Wow!
-Son of a gun!
-What?!
Cuban: Good for you.
What?!
That's incredible.
What are you gonna do --
Yeah, so year to date,
we've done $3.1 million.
And if we assume
that we just stop growing
from this point on out,
we'll do $7 million this year.
Cuban: You're dir--
Okay, you're direct to consumer,
which means you're doing
a lot of online advertising.
So tell us what your cost
to acquire these revenues are,
what your
gross margins are,
and what your
net margins are.
Yeah, so we spend about 20%
of our revenue on advertising.
Okay, that's not bad.
It costs us a blended CAC
of $16.
The average order value
is around $57.
Okay.
Wow. And they order one a kit
or more than one kit?
So that's about two kits.
Then you're making
a lot of money.
So 86% gross margin,
32% net margin lifetime,
and 38% year to date.
Great margins.
So why do you need $250,000?
I mean, you're killing it.
We're here
for three reasons.
We're here for licensing,
wholesale, and mentorship.
When it comes to licensing,
when a customer
finishes the kit,
the first thing they think is,
"I need to get another kit."
And then
they start asking us,
"Where's Baby Yoda? Do you have
any Disney characters?
Where are
the Marvel characters at?"
Guys, how did you arrive
at your valuation
that you presented?
Adrian: We know our valuation
is very low.
Low?
It's low because --
Yeah.
It's very low because
we are here to make a deal.
We can learn so much from this
group of people in this room,
and the way we see it,
we have two huge opportunities
ahead of us.
We haven't even begun
to talk about wholesale,
but licensing and wholesale
we think can drive this brand
to the next level.
You want to
go to retail?
We want to go to retail.
Why
when you're killing it?
'Cause they have enough
margin. Yeah.
We've -- We've done
a test order.
So now we get a little
more about what -- what
the mission really is.
Is the basis or the mechanism
for that learning,
in your vision,
always gonna be crochet?
Meaning is the next product
that you have coming,
a non-crochet
or some other form?
Yes, the -- the key
to our business
is the "learn to" part.
What we apply it to
can change.
But right now, we are 100%
focused on crochet.
So for the foreseeable future,
it's crochet kits.
Justine:
Exactly, yep.
I like this deal, okay?
'Cause it has something
I love called cash flow.
What does it have?
I love cash flow.
And so, I see
it this way.
I think I can reduce your costs
of acquiring customers
by around 8% to 10%.
Number two, I can definitely
help with licensing.
Been there, done that
with lots and lots of brands.
I also think I can help you with
some other interesting ideas
in the fashion world
with this stuff, okay?
The fashion world?
This I can't wait
to hear.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
Listen.
This is a far stretch.
Do you want to hear
the offer or not?
-We would love to.
-This is scary.
I'll you the $250,000
for 10% equity.
Coming from you,
Mr. Wonderful,
I expected to
hear the word "loyalty."
You know why? You know why?
You have cash flow.
Would it be okay
if we just heard
if any of the other Sharks
are interested, as well?
Corcoran:
I would definitely.
I'll give you $300,000
for the same 10%.
Thank you.
Greiner: I love this.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I'm gonna go
$300,000 for 10%.
I-I understand
all of this.
I mean, I've been in this
market so much,
and I know how to get all
the things you talked about
from the licensing
to the retail stores.
I think you should be
everywhere and fast
because you are something
that could really take off.
Justine: Exactly.
That's our mission.
We want to spread that joy
and confidence
of learning something new.
I'm gonna give you
$350,000 for 10%.
Cuban: No!
$300,000 for 8%.
O'Leary: Okay, and --
It's 8%.
This mentoring
is gonna be worth it.
Guys, you understand
all the offers, right?
You got to make a decision.
Hold it a second.
Just hold it a second.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
And there's a bidding war
between Barbara,
Kevin, and Lori for Adrian
and Justine's highly profitable
crochet kit business,
The Woobles.
I'm gonna give you
the $350,000 for 5%.
That's how much I believe
in your business.
You are sitting
on a rocket,
but you have to let me know
right away
'cause I'm being a fool here
bidding against myself.
Would you consider adding
another Shark to your offer?
I'll do it with Mark.
Come on, Mark. Come in with me.
Yeah.
I was $300,000 for 8%.
You don't need --
I can do this all alone.
We've read your book,
and we know --
we've seen what you've
been able to do.
I think that if you would
team up with another Shark...
What was the amount
you gave out?
$350,000.
The $350,000 for 6%.
Robert, are you gonna
do anything here?
Well, I'm trying to get
a word in here.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's hard.
I'm just seeing, how
can I get a piece of this?
Do you want Robert in it?
Make an offer.
Justine: Yes.
Oh.
I'd love to be involved.
So we're gonna give you
$450,000 for 6%.
The two of us together.
Cuban: There we go.
There's the answer.
That's a nasty move.
The two of us together.
Guys, you understand
all the offers, right?
You got to make
a decision.
Adrian:
Can we take a moment?
You can, you can.
Yes, yes.
What do you think?
[ Whispering
indistinctly ]
I'm not sure.
Let's just --
Let's just try.
Okay, so...
each Shark offers
a lot of different value
in different areas, and where
we think in the short term
that we can really get
the most help
is with Mark and Lori.
I feel offended.
And with Barbara --
But I want to let
you know that, like,
you mean so much to me, but --
but for the company, I think --
Oh, how sweet.
Lori, do you want
to work together?
But let me tell you --
Wait, you're gonna
abandon me like that?
Yes, it's over.
That's what they want to do.
$450,000, 6%?
You guys got a deal.
Oh, I've had it now!
Done? Yes?
Herjavec: Wow.
Deal. We'd love to work
with you guys.
Congratulations.
Adrian: Thank you.
Justine: Thank you.
Oh, my God, you guys,
it's so good.
You guys are great.
Thank you so much.
My God, he threw me
under the bus!
You guys are as sharky
as we are. Congrats.
Greiner: Yeah, yeah.
Oh, they're very sharky.
Greiner:
Good job, you guys.
Are we skipping?
Sure, yeah.
Skip out. [ Laughs ]
Mark and Lori
were our target Sharks.
We did not prepare for
that scenario at all,
and we're just glad
it worked out.
It was definitely a risky move
to try to break up
Barbara and Mark and get Lori
in there instead.
And we're glad
that it worked out.
Mark, I brought you
into the deal.
You didn't even want the deal.
I was pushing you for the deal.
You were my partner.
I never for a moment
thought you would
throw me under the bus
and go with Lori.
I really feel like
the scorned woman.
Herjavec:
See, I -- Barbara.
Robert knew.
Barbara,
that's the difference.
I knew Lori would
throw me under the bus.
[ Laughter ]
Narrator: In Season 6, we
watched Brad, Aimy, and Justin
make a deal with Mark Cuban
for their wine-based party punch
BeatBox Beverages.
Brad: BeatBox is
a party in a box.
It's almost seven bottles of
wine packed into every box.
Narrator: Let's see what
they're up to now.
When we went on "Shark Tank",
we were doing about $235,000
in sales with our 5-liter
bag-in-box party punch.
In the first year
after "Shark Tank",
our sales grew
to $750,000.
Then over the next two years,
sales kind of flatlined.
We launched in almost 400
Walmarts, and, uh, we failed.
It didn't work.
We couldn't sell it through.
The 5-liter bag-in-box
was a huge serving size,
and to ask consumers
to spend $20 is a big challenge.
That's when we decided to create
the single-serve Tetra Pak.
By doing the single-serve,
we lowered the price point
to under $5,
and when we did that,
our sales doubled
from $1 million to $2 million.
In 2019, they doubled again
to $4 million.
Since "Shark Tank", we've done
over $57 million in sales.
Whoa!
Justin: The success
of single-serve really
saved the business.
It allowed us to be
in a lot more stores
where the bag-in-box
just couldn't be sold.
Aimy: Our success has made it
so we were able to sponsor
tons of music festivals
and have a great time
with our customers and BeatBox.
Brad: We were in about
2,000 7-Elevens this year.
We went from having
one distributor
to now having
over 250 distributors
across 48 states.
It's absolutely
mind-blowing.
People today don't buy products.
They don't buy brands.
They buy part
of a community.
Aimy, Brad and Justin
are great entrepreneurs
because they're always looking
for new ways
to create experiences
for their customers,
and they have fun with it.
It's just a really cool,
really fun brand
that everybody can relate to.
You were able to fight your way
back from the depths
of BeatBox hell
to now be on top of the world
and changing the game.
My advice to entrepreneurs
out there is that the road
to success is certainly
not a straight line.
The entrepreneurial roller
coaster is very, very real.
You'll have some of
your best days ever
and some of
your lowest days ever.
But if you're passionate
about what you're bringing
to the world,
just don't give up.
To all our supporters
and to "Shark Tank"...
Together: Let's party!
Whoo!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a way
to bring a little frivolous fun
to your daily life.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Brian Brunsing,
and I'm from Buffalo, New York.
I'm Max Brown,
also from Buffalo, New York.
We're seeking $250,000
for 10% of our company.
Sharks, there
are three well-known problems
that need to be fixed
when it comes to
the 9:00-to-5:00
work life.
One, it's too boring.
Two, with all the constant
push notifications,
e-mails,
and text messages,
establishing real human
connection is almost impossible.
And three,
and this one's universal...
There's just not enough
fun in the world.
And that's bananas.
That's why we created...
Banana Phone!    Banana Phone!
[ Laughs ]
Banana Phone is
a banana-shaped
Bluetooth handset
that connects
to your smartphone.
So you can talk to
your friends, family,
or the IRS
on a banana.
We like to think of it
as a phone with appeal.
Baked into this
delicious design
is everything you need
to spark real conversations.
Once paired
with your smartphone,
this robust banana
is ready to receive calls
at the push of a button.
Yellow?
Or you can initiate calls
by clicking
the multifunction button
twice and saying,
"Call the banana man."
Voice: Calling Mark Cuban.
[ Greiner laughs ]
You can also show off
your wild side
by bumping your
favorite tunes
by using your Banana Phone
as a speaker.
And we banana split
a portion of our proceeds
with the gorilla conservation
Gearing Up For Gorillas.
It's potassium with a purpose.
What can we say?
Talk more, smile more,
save gorillas.
And help us make
talking cool again with...
Banana Phone!     Banana Phone!
Ta-dum!
What did you guys do before
you got into the bananas?
I worked for Visa,
and this is a project
that I've been investing
tons of late nights,
weekends, and round-the-clock
work to support.
So this is a side hustle.
This is a side hustle,
correct.
Got it.
By day, I'm president
of Garrett Leather.
We're the world's largest
Italian upholstery
leather supplier.
How long have you
been in business?
We've been in business
for six years.
-Six years?
-Six years?!
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
Do we have
a Banana Phone in here?
You should certainly.
Brown: You should check it out.
Ah.
If it's six years old,
hit us with a little sales.
Sure, so we've done over
$1.6 million in lifetime sales.
What?!
Yeah, but --
$400,000 in net income.
Say what?!
What did you do
last year?
Last year
was $540,000 in sales.
Net income last 12 months
was $123,000.
I got to tell you,
it's more than I-I thought.
Greiner: When was the "aha"
moment you're just sitting there
going, "Oh, Banana Phone"?
In 2016, I was sitting
at my desk with
a banana in my hand,
trying to blow off a colleague,
saying, "I'm really busy."
And I said,
"Oh, my God, this has to exist."
[ Laughter ]
After a quick
Google search --
You know there's
a lot of people --
After a quick Google search,
I realized that it didn't.
And after a quick
Instagram search,
I realized that there were
45,000 other people
who were making that joke
at the same time.
Wow. Smart thinking.
And there's a Shark
in this room who's made
that joke, as well.
Oh, Barb.
Corcoran: Oh, yeah,
I use it all the time.
Brown: Do you remember
that, Barbara?
But that's a very broad net --
Tell us what it costs
if I want to buy it online and
what it costs you to land it.
So this nanner
costs $39.99 retail.
Oh!
That's a big banana!
Our landed cost is
$6 a unit.
Do you have a patent?
We did not pursue
a design patent...
What?
Shocking.
...because they're notoriously
easy to copy and to knock off.
So we pursued a trademark
to protect our brand.
But, Max, just to be clear,
it's not a phone.
You need to pair it
with a phone.
Brunsing: That's correct.
You just pair
your banana to your Apple.
Oh, thank you, Robert.
Herjavec: Got it, got it.
Guys, let me ask you this.
You did $540,000 last year.
Your total lifetime sales over
six years were $1.2 million.
What shifted to get
your sales to go boom?
In the last two years,
we've shifted to a robust
direct-to-consumer
advertising strategy,
leveraging Facebook,
Instagram, TikTok, Google.
It sounds
very expensive.
How much are you
spending on that?
We're spending
$9 per customer.
Is that your customer
acquisition, is 9 bucks?
That's actually
not that bad.
And what we are seeing
is that we hit people
with targeted advertising
for high impulse conversions,
and then when they
get the phone,
there's a virality to it because
they're posting on social media.
But nobody's full time
on this business.
Right.
Correct. Not right now.
Are you willing
to give up your careers
to support the banana?
That's the question.
If we have a strategic partner
who's willing to work
with us and leverage it,
absolutely.
Tell me what you're gonna
do with the $250,000.
The next horizon for us
is getting into
brick and mortar retail.
Oh.
Ugh!
I think that
this thing screams to be
in the "beyond" section
at Bed Bath & Beyond.
Ugh.
Guys, you know,
I think what you're trying to do
in retail is beyond insane.
I'm sorry.
It's not gonna work.
This is
a very eclectic category.
I do not need a Banana Phone
in my portfolio.
This is not a product for me.
I'm out.
You guys took a fruit and turned
it into money in your pocket.
Giving you $250,000 means
you've got to make $2.5 million
in profits for me
just to get my money back.
It's a great personal business,
but it's not a great fit for me.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you so much
for your consideration, Mark.
But congrats.
We really appreciate it.
Congratulations.
So many people have the idea,
but nobody ever puts it in play.
I'm just thinking of waking up
one day and saying,
"I'm in the banana phone
business,"
and I'm not sure I see
a scalable business
for an investor.
I'm out.
I'm not really an investor in
kitschy, like, novelty products
that much because I think
that they have
a spike and then a fall.
It's not really
the right product for me.
So I'm sorry. I'm out.
You know, I just object
to investing in your business
for one reason only,
which is I don't want you
working on this part time.
One half and one half
doesn't equal three.
Yeah.
All right?
It will not grow
if you do that.
It doesn't make sense,
so I'm out.
Thank you for
your consideration.
Thank you, guys.
Cuban: Good luck, guys.
Brown: Thank you all.
Good luck, guys.
Thank you all.
Bye.
♪♪
Who is that?
Somebody's calling 'cause
they just saw us on "Shark Tank"
and they want to place
a massive order?
Uh-huh.
Hey, Kevin. Guess what?
I just invested in a banana.
This sucks.
[ Laughs ]
Gorillas don't want this.
Believe me.
I can't believe we're
standing in front of
these doors right now.
Me neither.
This is awesome.
Yep.
Narrator: Next in the Tank
is a tool to ensure you get
a juicy bird every time.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Brian.
And I'm Kirk.
And we're here from the home
of the Pro Football
Hall of Fame -- Canton, Ohio.
We're here seeking $100,000
for a 10% stake in our company.
Sharks, have you ever cooked
a chicken that was so dry
it was barely edible?
Or served a turkey at
Thanksgiving
that was so parched your guests
wanted to offer it a drink?
Well, that's
why we created...
the Turbo Trusser!
The Turbo Trusser!
The Turbo Trusser is
a rapid trussing device
used when cooking
whole chickens and turkeys.
Trussing is
a technique that...
Keeps the wings
and legs close to the body.
...keeps the wings
It cooks a bird
more evenly.
Good save.
Traditionally, this is done
with butcher's twine,
which is messy
and hard to work with.
And this is
for the birds.
[ Chicken clucks ]
But with the Turbo Trusser,
keeping your dinner
nice and juicy
is a breeze.
Just hook the Turbo Trusser
right into place.
Closing up the cavity
and sealing all the juices
to cook a perfect bird.
Check out these
incredible results.
Herjavec: Ooh!
Sharks, you'll get
a delicious, juicy
chicken or turkey
every time.
And this product
is so universal,
you can use it in ovens,
grills, smokers,
roasters, rotisseries,
deep fryers,
and heck,
even air fryers.
And best of all, it's made
of food-grade stainless steel,
and it's dishwasher safe.
And it's made right here
in the good old USA.
So which one of you Sharks
wants to take a bite
out of the poultry
industry...
Together: And make
a cluck load of money?
So each one of you Sharks
on your table,
you have samples
of our two versions.
One's a chicken Turbo Trusser,
and one is made for turkeys.
And then you also have
some chicken that was cooked
with the Turbo Trusser
today.
Kevin, we'd love
to have you come up.
Go ahead and try it out.
I would love to.
We've got a chef hat.
You know, I am Chef Wonderful.
That's right.
This is really good.
And of course,
we've got the apron.
It is very good.
[ Laughs ]
That's good.
Okay, you just pick
the Turbo Trusser up.
Yeah.
And set it in the butt there.
Okay. You set it
in the butt?
Set it in the butt.
Okay, the butt cavity.
And then lift the one leg up.
Oh, there we go.
Lift one leg up
and put it in.
Life the other leg up.
It's just that easy.
Good.
And then the other side,
do the same.
What is the chicken community
saying about
this torture device?
They really like it.
[ Laughs ]
We've sold about
11,000 units and had one return.
Wow.
Very nice.
Brian:
People really love it.
You don't have to get
your hands all messy
when you're using
butcher's twine.
How much of this delicious
juiciness is because of this
or the way you cooked it
in that particular oven?
It's because of
the Turbo Trusser.
That's what trussing
does it.
It cooks it
so you're cooking
one piece of meat
instead of five.
So it's gonna
cook more evenly.
I don't cook,
so I'm learning so much.
Does everybody do this?
You know what?
I think a lot of people do.
But I think people are,
one, afraid to do it with twine
'cause it's --
it's intimidating
if you don't
know how to do it.
Oh, yeah, like, if you told me
to tie up a dead chicken,
I'd be, like...
Normally got to go online,
watch a 5- or 10-minute video.
So, guys,
how did you get here?
You know, how did you get
in chicken suits
on "Shark Tank", on the carpet?
Yeah, tell us your story.
For the last 18 years,
I've been working
in the pharmaceutical
industry.
I've worked for three of
the largest
pharmaceutical companies
in the world.
But Kirk and I, we met about
five or six years ago.
He was renovating
my house.
I was a contractor
for 20 years.
I went to culinary school
back in the early '90s.
I was a sous chef in a -- in a
couple big banquet kitchens
and country clubs,
but I got burnt out,
and that's how I got
into contracting.
As a contractor,
I found a problem
with straight
shut-off valves.
I invented a wrench
that has over 800 positions,
and I have
two utility patents
and I think five
design patents on it.
And I ended up
licensing it.
And then Brian's like, "I want
to start inventing, too.
This is really cool."
And I'm like,
"Okay, well, let's do it."
Yeah, it was that easy, right?
We're gonna invent our way
into chicken suits.
Right.
We've invented personally
together six products,
four in the barbecue industry,
two in the pet industry.
And then he's got
a wrench.
Before this product,
did you make any money?
Not a dime.
No.
[ Laughter ]
Not a dime.
But you know what?
We kept inventing.
O'Leary: Let's get back to this
product for a second.
How much does it cost?
How much do you make it for?
How many have you sold?
So right now, it costs --
well, on our last order,
it was $3.07 to make,
MSRP is $14.99.
And how many have you
sold in dollars?
$90,000 in sales.
So we've been in business
for eight and a half months.
60% of our sales
come from our website alone.
27% of our sales
go through distributors.
We have three distributors.
We're in 75 stores now.
Oh, you are? And how is it
selling? Is it selling through?
Yep.
Yep. Selling through.
All three of our
distributors have reordered.
We have somebody that's selling
on Amazon for us now.
He's reordered
three times.
Herjavec: Uh, Brian, I love you
guys. I love this thing.
I know nothing about it.
It's just not big enough for me.
Don't chicken out.
[ Laughter ]
Not yet.
Our margin's 82%.
O'Leary: He's a turkey.
Well done.
Brian, Kirk, I love it.
Not for me.
Thank you. Thank you, Robert.
Thank you for your time.
Appreciate it.
Brian, how would I make money
on a deal like this?
It seems like a little business,
a little bit of sales.
Doesn't seem like there's room
for a third person by any means.
Barbara,
that's a great question.
87 million turkeys
are consumed
just between
the three holidays
of Thanksgiving,
Easter, and Christmas.
We're not online
marketing experts, right?
So we're
looking for somebody
that can help us
with some marketing,
get us some
social media exposure.
But, guys, look, it's hard
to connect your product
to all those turkeys
and chickens.
I-I just don't see you
being able to scale,
which makes it really
difficult as an investor.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you very much
for your time.
Thank you, Mark.
So it's not
really investable for me.
It's not big enough, and I
really hate touching chicken.
So I just have to be honest
about that.
[ Laughs ]
And for those reasons, I am out.
But I think you'll do
really well.
We appreciate that feedback.
Thank you.
Brian, it's not
a big enough business for
an investor to make money.
I'm out.
Brian, you've got -- you've got
one turkey left.
O'Leary:
You know, guys, I look at this,
and I see the potential of it,
but there's so much work.
We don't want you guys to do
the work for us.
We're gonna do the work.
Listen, we're here.
We won't let you down.
We just need
your connections.
I mean, imagine if
Chef Wonderful
took this under his wing.
We would love to have
you under the wing.
Would love that.
But he ain't free.
He's an expensive chef.
I mean, I wish you'd had a model
already put out there
where I just had
to pour gasoline on it.
They do. They have
a product here you can sell.
So I have to don my whites.
I have to be Chef Wonderful.
I have to sell a lot of these
to make any money.
Um...
I mean, I -- Ugh.
We're flexible
in our equity.
We're here
to make a deal.
Yep.
Yes, I know that.
God,
this is a royalty deal.
I-I can't believe you're not
mentioning that.
It's definitely a royalty deal.
The question is how much.
Let him talk.
I mean, how -- to get
Chef Wonderful
to back this,
and he's greedy.
The only way I would do this --
I'll give you the $100,000.
I want 33%,
but wait, there's more.
I want a dollar royalty
in perpetuity
for every one we sell.
Herjavec: Wow.
What a greedy bastard.
Whoa, whoa.
Wow.
We appreciate
that offer.
Would you do that deal
for 20% and the $1 royalty?
No, no.
Kevin.
I want to be
the third chicken.
I see this as being
something I can really
get to town on, but I've got to
make it worth my while.
I have to wet my beak.
We know it. 25%?
Look, let's -- let's be honest
with each other.
Your -- Your other inventions
were, well, dogs.
We don't want that
to happen here.
And I don't let dogs
on my watch. Okay?
I think I can make this
make money for all of us.
I want to be
the third chicken.
That's very reasonable, I think,
given the amount of work --
A dollar, and when you wholesale
this, guys,
you're not gonna have
all that much left.
Right. Exactly.
I know.
Unless you get the price
really way down.
Well, then make
them an offer, Lori.
You have one offer.
Is anybody else like
to come back in?
O'Leary: May I remind you two
something else.
Bertello Pizza Oven,
the largest selling
direct-to-consumer
pizza oven in America --
C'est moi.
Chef Wonderful.
Could you do the 33%
without the -- without
the dollar a unit royalty?
Never gonna happen.
Oh, guys, this guy's
a bottom fisher.
I don't know, man.
You don't have
to do it, guys.
Yeah, I know.
Um, 30%?
No.
Kevin!
You can walk away, guys.
♪♪
This is a lot of work,
this deal.
And I'm the only Shark
willing to do it with you.
So there's a price.
I give you an offer.
You have to make a decision.
Dollar a unit royalty.
Man, that's rough.
Take it?
Let's take it.
You got a deal.
Winner, winner, chicken dinner.
Yes, indeed.
Greiner: Winner, winner,
chicken dinner.
Congrats, Kev.
Corcoran: Good job, guys.
Thanks, guys.
Cuban:
Do the Funky Chicken, Kev.
Thank you so much.
We appreciate you very much.
Greiner: Congrats, guys.
"Shark Tank" is the things
dreams are made of.
We appreciate it.
Cuban: Hell yeah.
Thank you.
We couldn't walk away
from a deal with Chef Wonderful.
There is
no opportunity greater
than to have
a Shark on your team.
Royalty or not...
Together: We're gonna make
a cluck load of money!
[ Chicken clucks ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a brand
that merges function with style.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Braxton Fleming,
and I'm from
Mays Landing, New Jersey.
And I'm seeking $200,000
in exchange for 15% equity
of my company.
Six years ago, the trajectory
of my whole life changed.
I realized...
I was transgender.
With this realization
came with a lifelong commitment
of taking
hormone replacement therapy
in the form of injections.
During my first year
of transitioning,
there was nowhere
to properly store
my medical needs in a safe,
neat, discreet, yet stylish way.
That's where Stealth Bros & Co.
revolutionized the way
that we store our meds
and dispose of our sharps.
This was born out of my own need
as a trans man,
but I realized there were
multiple underrepresented
medical communities
who needed this product.
Who do you know
that's a diabetic?
Or maybe you know someone going
through infertility treatment,
a child with injectable needs,
or even cisgendered individuals
going through hormone
replacement therapy.
All of these underrepresented
medical communities
need options to travel
with confidence
for easy and proper
at-home storage.
That's where our Dopp kits
and Stealth sharp shuttles
come in and save the day.
It's time to upgrade
your plastic bags -- whew --
and your old jugs
and store your meds in luxury.
So, Sharks, who wants to fill
the void of millions of people
and take a shot
with Stealth Bros & Co.?
Let's go!
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: Yeah.
Yes.
So we can have a look
at this here?
Absolutely.
Please open up your bags and
take a look at what you have.
Herjavec: What do we
have in front of us, Braxton?
Okay, so what you have
in front of you
is a junior Dopp kit and
a stealth sharp shuttle inside.
So the junior Dopp kit
that you have is
our foundational
junior Dopp kit,
which is in line
with our sword interior.
And then, Lori,
you have our premium Dopp kit,
which is made
with our vegan faux leather.
So your medicines
and everything can go in here?
The vials?
Yes, that is
for the vials.
What's a sharp?
So a sharps is part of
your injectable needs.
It's a needle?
It's a biohazard container.
Absolutely.
To put your needle it.
Well, after I use the needle,
I put it in here?
Yes. So you just pop this top
open like this.
And then it can close.
And you can open it
and close it multiple times.
Once it's filled,
then you want to take
that little latch at the top,
stick it in that compartment,
and then it locks permanently,
and then you can
discard it appropriately.
So this is the disposable
aspect of the needles.
Yes.
But does only one
come with your kit?
I would think you'd be
using these like crazy.
So, yes, we actually
offer them in bundles.
So you could buy it for one,
three, or five on my website.
And we just received
a major purchase order
from a large retailer,
and they will be sold
in a bundle pack of four.
There are other Dopp kits
for injectables, right?
'Cause I've seen
plenty of them.
Yes.
And so you just
made them more fashionable
and more fashion looking?
Correct.
And same with the sharps.
Absolutely.
Okay.
What was missing
from the other kits?
And is it
what Mark said?
Right, right.
You just made it
more fashionable and cool?
What was missing was
the effect that it was daunting
to take the injection
for me.
Even though I'm a nurse,
I've been a nurse
for the past 11 years,
I realized that, yes,
I give injections every day,
but when I was watching
the YouTube videos online
of my community
taking these injections,
I was realizing how much anxiety
was bri-- it was bringing them.
Sure.
And once I created something
that organized
everything for them,
they weren't all over the place.
I want to bring an experience
to the user.
I want them to feel good
about themselves.
And this brings happiness
to my community,
and that's what
I'm trying to do here.
How do you reach your community?
How do you sell the product?
So I sell the product
all through e-commerce,
and I've just been growing
organically through influencer.
And now would be
a good time to ask you,
how much
have you sold?
Year to date, currently,
we're at $110,000.
That's good.
Herjavec: And last year,
what did you do,
Braxton?
We did $147,000.
So we're up 40%
currently right now.
What does this cost to make,
and what do you sell it for?
Okay, so the one that you have
costs $5.80 for me,
and then I sell it
for $34.
$34?
Greiner:
That's a big margin.
On the sharp stuff, what
your cost is for one of these?
Fleming: Okay.
And what you're gonna sell
the one, three, and four pack,
I guess.
Okay, so if we buy over
10,000 pieces of that,
it's at 28 cents,
and then we sell them
for $4 on the website.
And then if you buy
a pack of five, it's $15.
And what are you gonna
sell it for wholesale
to the retailer?
So I sell it
to them for $7.50,
and then they're reselling it
for $14.99.
So $7.50 for a pack of four.
And it cost you 28 cents?
Yes. Thank you.
Herjavec: Mark's gonna
start selling them.
Braxton, can you tell us
a little bit about
yourself
and your background?
Absolutely. Absolutely.
So I actually come from
two entrepreneurial parents,
and as I was growing up,
I was very accepted
in my family.
You know, my parents loved me.
They never judged me.
They let me be
whoever I wanted to be.
And at the age of
27 years old, I said,
"Something is missing
from my life."
And that's when I realized
that I was transgender.
And once I made that change,
as I was watching
YouTube videos of other
trans men taking
hormone replacement injections,
that's how I realized
that there was
a need for this.
And I was indirectly
assessing them
with my nursing skills, saying,
"Oh, that's not safe."
Like, they're putting it
in shoe boxes,
they're putting it
in plastic bags.
And that's when I said,
"You know, I really want
to become a part of my community
because they've given me so much
that I wanted to give back."
I created this brand,
and it just blew up.
Is it just you
running the business?
It's all me.
I do everything.
I literally work out
of my basement right now.
I have all my product
down there.
Are you still doing this
completely out of your basement?
Yes. 100%.
And are you nursing
still, or...?
Yes, I've actually been trying
to slow down
because I've been putting
more effort into the business.
I'm just curious,
the logo,
Stealth Bros and Co.
Yes.
When you came out here,
I thought --
Cuban: It's a great name now.
Now that we know
and understand it, it's great.
I'll explain the name.
Stealth is because
I wanted people to be able
to keep their
medication discreet.
No, I get
the stealth part.
Why the Bros and Co.
and the swords?
And Bros is, we're built
on the foundation
of the brotherhood of F-to-M --
female to male brotherhood.
I see.
And then "& Co."
is & communities
that we keep,
our allied communities.
That's great.
And then the swords
are there for because
iron sharpens iron,
and more than one community
coming together
makes you better and stronger,
and that what --
Do you have that up on your
website, the explanation?
I actually do not.
You should. It's cool.
I should. Thank you.
You should.
That's very cool.
And there should be
a video there
of you explaining it
because the power
of how you
just explained it...
Yes.
Yeah.
...that comes across
very, very well.
Thank you.
I think that it's kind of
the -- the perfect kit,
and I love what you're doing
for the community.
I don't think
you need a partner.
I don't always say that.
I rarely say it.
I think
you should run this.
I think you should take
all the profit.
And I think you should
grow step by step.
And you're gonna have
a wonderful business
and reap what you sow.
And for those reasons, I wish
you good luck, but I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
I appreciate it.
So, Braxton, the greatest
part of your business,
not to diminish the other
parts of your business,
is really you.
Thank you.
I mean, you exude
an incredible warmth.
Thank you.
And personality
that draws people to you.
Thank you.
I think you've got
a good business.
Just at the size
you are right now,
just not something
for me.
I'm out.
I wish you all the best.
Thank you.
Corcoran: I've had some
personal experience.
When I was trying
to get pregnant,
I was doing in-vitro
for seven years
to give birth to
my first born.
Wow.
Thank God it worked.
God bless you.
I remember being
in business meetings,
in museums...
Yes.
...in theaters where
it's time to take my big shot.
Right.
It was just as big as this.
Yeah.
With a big plunger.
And it was made of oil
that burned when it went in.
That's right.
It was horrible.
Yeah.
But the ingenious ways
I had to come up with
just to hide that.
Not that I was ashamed,
but what do you do with
the damn needle?
Right, right.
You know, my life had to go on.
I used to carry
books with me,
cut out pages in the middle,
cut a page, like a spot.
Wow.
And carry the book
and stick
the needles in there.
Because you can't dispose
in a restroom.
You can't throw it
in a garbage can.
But let me
tell you something.
You have genuine warmth
and love
that your pitch
comes from.
Thank you.
You feel it all over.
And you know what?
I'm a believer,
if you're that sincere...
Yes.
...and you come from
that love spot...
Yes.
...people always do well.
And they buy. They just buy.
It's like a magic wand.
And I think it's terrific
what you do.
Thank you so much, Barbara.
Thank you.
So I'm gonna
make you an offer.
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out,
and Barbara seems interested
in Braxton's medical Dopp kit
company Stealth Bros & Co.
Corcoran: I think
it's terrific what you do.
Thank you so much, Barbara.
Thank you.
I'm gonna make you
an offer...
Okay.
...of $200,000, but I don't want
to put in all cash.
I'm gonna give you
$100,000 in a credit line,
$100,000 cash.
Okay.
And I do want 20%
of the business
'cause I want to feel happy
when you do well and make money.
So I'd like to be part
of that celebration with you.
Yes.
Yeah.
I-I think it has merit.
I think you
have made something
much more fashionable
and interesting to own.
I get it.
Barbara, do you want
any help?
Or you want to
do it yourself?
You want to jump in?
I think it's a good cause.
Yeah, I'll split it with you
if you want.
Yeah. Okay.
I like the fact
you know your numbers.
Right.
But it's not a product
that's gonna fit for me.
Okay.
But I wish you the best.
You're a good guy.
The presentation was very good.
Thank you, Kevin.
I'm out, but you do have
an offer from a Sharkette.
And Mark is still,
I believe.
No, I'm -- I'm very interested,
and Barb and I were talking.
From an operational
perspective,
it's not just
a cash issue.
It's building your
business issue, as well.
Yes, it is.
Because you're
doing it yourself,
trying to scale it from
the basement to a business...
Correct.
...is going to be
a lot of work,
and I think between
our two organizations,
we -- we can complement each
other to get you there.
Absolutely.
And so if it works with you,
Barb and I will split it.
So it's going to be $200,000,
$100,000 of that in cash,
and $100,000 of that
as a line of credit for 20%.
What do you think,
Braxton?
Wow. That's amazing.
What do you think?
Um...
It wouldn't be right
if I didn't counter.
So, are you guys willing
to go to 18%?
Well...
You guys got a deal.
-You got it.
-Oh, yes!
Congratulations!
Thank you so much.
It's such a pleasure, Mark.
Congratulations.
Appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Barbara.
My pleasure.
Congrats.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Cuban: Congrats.
Thank you.
This was a pleasure.
Fleming: I'm so excited.
I-I cannot believe that
I just secured a deal
with Mark and Barbara.
I'm just like...
Oh, my God. I just...
I prayed so hard for this.
♪♪
For my family, for my community,
for everybody.
♪♪